owning a cat is like having a furry ball
of mischief and unconditional love
wrapped into one maybe that's why I have
four um that's right I am so crazy in
love with cats um that I have four of
them I've become that woman you know the
crazy cat lady I'm her um and it's true
and uh the very first job I ever did in
life um was when I was 11 months old
with Purina I did their gainsburger
Puppy Chow commercial it was my first
job guess what I'm teaming up with Pur
and a catchow to celebrate their
Milestone 60th anniversary and the
release of their new book um called 60
years 60 stories it's a collection of 60
powerful stories from cat owners and in
the book you're going to find
heartwarming stories of a cat named
blueberry who's providing thousands of
people with emotional support take a
look at this clip you'll see what I mean
I'm Melissa and I'm the executive
director at Community Helping place in
delaia Georgia and I am blueberry's
owner blueberry was initially a stray
who was rescued by the local animal
shelter and we hired him for pest
control but blueberry had other plans he
has become another social worker
blueberry senses right away when someone
comes in that they need a friend he hops
right on their lap and he loves on them
having blueberry here has been a
GameChanger and we couldn't be
happier joining us is Melissa line and
Serita pet behavioralist Dr Annie vesa
hi everybody how's it going great Dr
Annie why do we love our pets why are
they so emotionally stabilizing and
comforting for us I mean in short pets
and people really are better together um
the results of one study suggest that
cat owners may have a reduced risk of
cardiovascular disease compared to
non-cat owners good news that's great
and partly that may be due to the fact
that just 10 minutes of petting a cat
can significantly reduce cortisol which
is a stress hormone stress is so real um
and I love that animals scientifically
are known um to reduce stress absolutely
and good news um cats enjoy us too so
there was a really cool study that asked
cats whether they preferred things like
pets food a toy that found that cats
Most Wanted human interaction and really
yeah I'm so glad that they prefer humans
that's such good news Well Melissa tell
us about your Community Helping place
because your cat blueberry is like the
Ambassador why did you think I'm going
to have a cat being an ambassador to my
Community Helping Place Well Community
Helping place is a nonprofit serving
between 15 and 20,000 individuals per
year we have a food pantry and a free
medical clinic that offers Medical
Dental mental health counseling free
Transportation financial assistance uh
to anyone in need in our community
they've actually been around for over 35
years and it was initially a food pantry
started by a Catholic priest in our
community I've been the executive
director for about 5 years it it is the
greatest joy of my life but I've always
worked in nonprofit so why did you get
into nonprofits well I can't imagine not
having a job um that was about serving
the less fortunate and um I just thank
God for that opportunity well I thank
God for you to do that with and for
people all right well our entire
audience is going to go home with a copy
of 60 years 60 stories that's available
now through December 31st and the
proceeds from the book directly support
pet partners the leading nonprofit for
registering volunteer therapy animal
teams and um Melissa in honor of
everything you're doing Pur and a cat
child 60 years of providing time proven
nutrition that cats love and cats owners
trust they want to donate
$10,000 to your organization Community
Helping
F thank you that's
incredible by the way I heard you're a
fan of the Pittsburgh Steelers well our
entire family is yes yes especially my
husband he's a big fan really yes well
then that's fun because cam Hayward of
the Pittsburgh Steelers also heard about
your organization and wanted to send you
a quick message hi Melissa line this
this is Cam Heyward from the Pittsburgh
Steelers I just wanted to congratulate
you on all the great work you're doing
got to hear about your cat blueberry but
just want to give a big shout out to you
and your staff for all the work you're
doing and continue to keep doing best of
luck and
go thank you so much Kina I love you
thank you to Pina catchow thank you to
you guys we'll be right
[Music]
back